And, uh, how many people's at 20,000.
[inaudible] and Elton John held
the record before we broke it.
And the reason we broke it as we
were in a center stage in the middle,
and there's only four of us
doing stand up. So it was,
there's nobody will ever have a smaller
stage. Wow. For that show there.
Right. How could they, and that was right
before we film blue collar. One two done.
Josh Wolfe showed me a picture when
you opened up for Larry, the cable guy,
you will open up at some football arena.
He's on stage and he takes it like a
selfie out. Looking at the audience.
It's the craziest thing you've ever
seen your life. See if you can find it.
Josh Wolfe, uh, opening up for
Larry, the cable Guy Selfie.
It's fun. I don't even know if he put it
online. He showed it to me on his phone.
It's fucking bananas. There's
50,000 people there, you know,
50,000. But yeah, he was doing,
he was doing crazy, crazy,
crazy numbers and say numbers and
didn't even talk about it. You know,
there was a lot of people that are hating
on him. He couldn't be a nicer guy.
He's also a great pace, rhythm and
timing. One lander guys, you know,
and uh, as good as a gets, I've seen him
just beat crowds to death. Funny Dude.
And uh, and gifted. And also it was done.
It totally paid his dues.
You know how many percent I met him in 92.
I think you've known him
longer than I have shit. Look
at that fucking guy, right?
Yeah. I haven't played this
place. Look at that fucking crowd.
That's gotta be the guy that's gotta
be in Nebraska, right? So, right.
Everybody's right. There's gotta be a
borrow state stadium in Lincoln, Nebraska.
That is one of the most insane
crowds I've ever seen in my life.
But it makes sense. He's got great
fucking timing, man. And I met him,
like I said,
in 92,
I think at the comedy works in Montreal
when Jimbo used to run the joint and he
was a great guy, man back then. Even
back then, he was a, I think he was a,
it was a radio personality in
Florida at the time, you know,
he's just [inaudible] the cable guy was
a character he did in that and that he
would bring into a show for one joke and
then it kind of just took over fucking
crazy. And people don't know, like he's
Dan Whitney. He's like a regular person.
Regular. Yeah. But he's trapped. Right.
He is Larry the cable trap it a place
you'd like to be trapped, right? Oh yeah,
yeah.
Making $30 million a year.
It's like this marvelous Mrs Maizel thing.
Except he's, that's who he actually is.
I mean, he doesn't have to wear a fat
suit or anything crazy, but you know,
his dad was a preacher and a
pig farmer from Nebraska. Wow.
And, uh, and so he does this,
a great auctioneer boys where [inaudible]
has sold a little Danny Whitney from
across the street. Wow. A
preacher in a pig farmer.
Holy Shit.